that verdict unanimous it is we going to
count one attempted murder of Lauren
kanarack what is your verdict Not Guilty
by reason women said
with regard to count two attempted
murder
of Robert Goodwin what is your verdict
sir
all right welcome back everybody well
the Pike County Massacre trial takes
their lunch break our coverage moves
over to Morristown New Jersey and what
you just saw was former Olympian Michael
barrisone now residing in a psychiatric
facility following his trial back in
April that was the verdict that you just
heard Barrison remember was found not
guilty by means of insanity back in
April for attempting to kill his
equestrian student Lauren canarak along
with her boyfriend in 2019. baritone
stood trial earlier this year with his
defense team putting on the case that
kanarack drove barason over the edge
using social media to taunt him and
damage his reputation now following his
Insanity verdict he was transferred to a
psychiatric hospital and as of this
month he is in now in a less restrictive
facility pending a follow-up in six
months but to get a little context into
how this case played out let's look back
at some of the closing arguments on both
sides
in the defendant know and appreciate the
nature and quality of his eyes that's
the other part of the insanity defense
so if you believe that the defendant has
convinced you that he was delusional
that's not the end of the inquiry
you still have to decide whether that
delusional disorder
made it such that he didn't know the
nature and quality of his Acts or that
he didn't know what he was doing was
wrong and the judge is going to tell you
you do not have to rely just on the
doctors for this you can rely on your
common sense you can rely on the other
evidence that you heard
what did the other evidence show
all the same things that established
that the defendant wanted to kill
show that he knew the nature and quality
of his actions everything had fallen
apart
the working relationship the business
relationship the social relationship the
farm is getting shut down police are
there Town officials are coming lawyers
are sending fake eviction notices
everything has fallen apart
then I ask
from a common sense perspective
what's the trigger what makes it on
August 7th 2019 defendant hasn't seen
Lauren or Rob at all that day what makes
the delusion at that point click turns
off his memory and makes him say I have
to go kill or be killed this delusion of
fear has now driven me to have to go and
kill
it's the dyf Escape
caseworker showing up there
not to say
born in love
called us
said something about you
because then it isn't sitting in his
office doesn't look out the window and
see a bird flying overhead and believe
that the bird was sent to spy on him by
Lauren and Rob and if he has to go kill
them
for her there
and he decides in that moment to act
impulsively to act emotionally and to
act purposely and to go try and kill
Lauren and Robin
so I would suggest
the evidence shows that the defendant
did not carry his burden with respect to
the insanity defense
what was cataract's motivation
she admitted to a plan to destroy him in
the business
that plan included attacking him on
social media
accusing him falsely
of neglecting horses insurance fraud
falsely claiming bullying and
threatening her life
she had a plan to scare him
remember the text that was was that I
questioned her about
we have to scam Michael Barrison
and then the various texts after that
where she's talking about Michael
barrisone being scared totally different
circumstances
I submitted she had a plan to cause him
to flee his own house
by scaring him
talking about
weapons incessantly sleeping with a gun
underneath her pillow
having two guns two nine millimeter guns
talking about killing the King
sacrificing the queen destroying the
castle
talking incessantly about going to war
it's time Wars inevitable why would
anyone
say those things unless they were trying
to drive someone over the edge
what possible legitimate purpose would
they have
attacking him like that
So based on how this case panned out was
Michael bearstone better off in jail or
in the mental health facility Murray
what do you think I think clearly he
needed help and I think being in the
mental facility will allow them to give
him that psychiatric help that he needs
it does have drawbacks because
you have to remain and I don't want to
say incarcerated but in the institution
until the doctors deem you safe to be
let out in the community and not harmful
to yourself or others so you can
actually serve a longer sentence under
those terms than you would if you were
found guilty of the crime but not by
reason of insanity well you speak about
the sentence and Michael I want to get
your thoughts on this do you think he'll
ever be released completely
I think he's going to be released I
think he's going to have to stay for a
good while in some sort of custodial
Arrangement and the reason for that is
the defense theory of the case is
essentially this guy was harassed so
much that he went crazy and he ended up
over in their apartment or their
dwelling and at best he was involved in
some kind of mutual combat with the
boyfriend at worst he did an attempted
murder and that depends on who you
believe and how the blow by blow exactly
went I know the boyfriend
got the better of the fight after his
girlfriend was shot and he ended up on
top and um the defendant took a big
beating and now there's going to be some
civil litigation which we can go into
but clearly Jeopardy attached uh there's
no there's a bar to a Criminal suit and
he's it's better to be in a mental
facility than to be in prison for
attempted murder for sure well it's
interesting Maria as we look at those
images you just see a very insane
looking Michael barrisstone in that
verdict and those are one of the last
images that we have seen of Michael
barrisone and when you're his team and
you want him to have his sentence be
lessened I mean do you depict a certain
picture now saying hey this was what he
was and it's only getting worse for him
so give the man some break oh absolutely
they did a really great job at
convincing those jurors that he was
incapable of forming any type of
malicious intent which is required by
this crime it's there's men's area you
have to intend to commit the act and
they basically said he was incapable of
appreciating right from wrong now while
he's in the institution with proper
treatment it would be time for him to
start acting right so that they can deem
him releaseable soon they no doubt
painted a very good picture showing just
how insane and demented Michael Barrison
is in this state